we're hanging in Miami Beach with the
sexy stars of Baywatch the ladies are
right over there not these guys no no
I'm somewhat the lady the ladies yes
they are you were getting pumped in
between takes and gotta do it man you
had to do it I get up at 3:45 in the
morning yeah and I go in the shower make
myself wet take some selfies like I
worked out go back to bed he's joking
Dwayne plays Mitch the head lifeguard
who was originally played by David
Hasselhoff in the series The Hoff is
actually shot a cameo in Sully's Pamela
Anderson Zak is Matt originally David
Charvet
the young new hotshot it's gonna be
prettier dirtier more are hardcore
funnier the language yet raunchy you're
talking about it what like of course
there'll be a beach full of Baywatch
babes
Kelly Rohrback is CJ Pamela's role I
want to know about these bathing suits
all the girls have suits sort of based
on their personalities and CJ is
definitely the more flirtatious and
free-spirited of the malls and Rose is a
little bit smaller Stephanie Holden
played by Alexander Paul is the more
conservative one of the bunch so
everybody that's afraid that there
aren't gonna be enough they are coming
they are just not mine here's the tough
part of alexandra daddario gig she's
Zacks love interest in the movie that is
just terrible it's hell isn't it it's
just awful I mean look at him over there
it's ridiculous blah blah
of course fans are a constant in Miami
on the beach unfortunately so were the
prying paparazzi
I just noticed there's all those
paparazzi everywhere you guys move on
set the first I was something like give
me my row between every take now my god
whatever okay even more motivation not
to eat ice cream
how is it doing that slow motion run
have you done one of those yet ah oh
yeah don't don't uh you ran a lot faster
than me that's so stupid I had so much
fun there let me give you another set
secret in between their shots zac efron
of the rock would pull out these
resistance bands and they start working
out to get bigger definitely get all
this butter whoo